religion for example like which rubs
people perhaps the wrong way but
no one on the planet is christian no one
right they may subscribe to the tenants
of christianity
that's a very different it's semantic
but it's incredibly important because
to me why why i'm not into religion so
much is it tends to create diversity
right it
creates division so when a baby's born
the baby doesn't even know its own name
it doesn't know it's gender it certainly
doesn't know what religion apparently
ascribes to
so to declare that i am something i am
is the root
you know that is the precursor to how we
define ourselves
right so it's it's not wrong it's just
inaccurate you know
like to say i'm muslim i'm buddhist i'm
christian
it's not wrong it's just inaccurate it's
not a truth but as soon as you become
collapsed with it's no different than
someone saying i'm fat
that equally isn't true but as soon as
you become identified with the words
that
follow the i am then you think that's
who you are and you're going to defend
it which is why you know there's so much
bloodshed so um that's where i have
issue with
any of that you know whereas as soon as
we declare something
certainly that has been uh generational
like you know if you're parents with
this and that
whatever it might be your parents could
be overweight and now i'm overweight
like it doesn't have to be specific to
religion
it's just whatever we inherit in the way
that we define ourselves
then anything that is in contrast to
that or conflict to it is gonna
meet resistance and that's where it gets
ugly
so what is the correct use of i am
well it's about as far as you can go ask
your
question no there's i am like that's it
right like
it's i mean we're going down deep here
but when i really got that
i am what more do i need was one of my
quotes
right so i i'm sure you're familiar with
my work that's how it comes through me
is
these short quotes and insights and i
see i really got to the point of where i
shared
so many of the different levels of who i
thought i was and all the different
layers of my particular persona
that i got to i am what more do i need
and within i am is everything
which of course it starts to become
esoteric but i
am nurse is consciousness god love
whatever you want to call it to me the
absolute so i
am is all potentialities then we declare
who we are on top of that so that's why
i love you know working with actors over
the years because they do this for a
career right they they pretend to be
somebody
tom hanks wasn't gay and dying of hiv
but he played that in philadelphia so he
could say i
am whatever his character was michael
but he knows
when he goes home that he's straight and
he's married and
apparently not dying of aids right so
he's pretending
the trouble is the persona that we take
home from a very young age is still a
pretense it's just we do it for three
four five decades
so we think that's who we are as opposed
to remembering no i'm all
i'm all possibilities but i've declared
myself in such a way and often it's not
a choice it was something that was given
to me
you're being told by a parent you're
being told by a teacher this is who you
are
you're a failure you're not good enough
and then we adopt that and
that becomes the mental prison and then
people live in the for the majority of
their lives so
well i like to pull both sides of the
spectrum right so you've got the i am a
victim
i am sick i am you know miserable
i am fat i am ugly whatever i am danica
but could we not reframe this in a way
that is
of equal strength and power in a
positive way like i
am well i mean i feel actually i feel so
i feel so wayne dyer
right now right um the i am that i am
discourses or whatever
yeah i think is a book maybe you wrote
um but i
am well like i am happy i am successful
like i am peaceful
yeah can we not use it the other is
there a way to use i
am a hundred percent that's just the
root
you know so for sure this is you know my
work is dissolution i don't say i solve
people's problems i dissolve them so
what i'm dissolving is the
the the current attachment to the i am
that tends to to veer towards the
derogatory the deleterious the negative
the limited
but then yes once you remove that you
step back into
what we could say is this realm of all
opportunities pure potential
and then through declaration we get to
say something else so yes
i am extraordinary like one of my
favorite athletes who actually is just
he's an mlb player we worked together
for six seasons
he had five six all-stars in a row just
incredible success and it was just so
fun to work together he took a couple
years off and he just i've spoke to him
this morning so he's asked to work with
me again this season
and one of my favorite conversations
with him he was
he was pretty relentless as an athlete
super disciplined
incredibly determined and one of the
words we played with as a declaration
was unstoppability what does that look
like
especially in baseball it's a game of
failure right like three out of ten and
you're an all-star like that's that's
not good
ratio right to be 30 percent and yet
you're an all-star
speaks to how much failure there is in
the game as a hitter
so anyway i asked him the question i
said so what why are you unstoppable
and he came up with you know all of
these incredibly valid responses
well you know i'm i'm dedicated i put in
the work
reasons that justified being unstoppable
but because of the virtue by virtue of
our conversation and how i worked with
him i said well those
aren't wrong they're not inaccurate but
what i'm asking you to look at is
you're unstoppable because you say so
and he still to this date cites that
conversation he's like
wow like it's a declaration of who i be
who i am that is the container that i
step
within that shows up the discipline and
the dedication and the professionalism
it's not because of those things i
declare myself to be unstoppable
and then i honour my word which is
really the power of language so why i
use the expression words of the wardrobe
for the soul
so our soul is limitless but by virtue
of the words we use it will
contain whatever is potential it will
create the limitations invariably
because most people's words are
like you said limited but once we remove
that constraint then we get to declare
words that are more expansive
so for me i say like i'm i'm the
luckiest human being on the planet
now where's the evidence for that other
than my declaration to it which then
becomes self-fulfilling
it's really it pulls for the the
opportunity
for me to vibrate and feel at a certain
level but then also
the magic of how life can show up by
virtue of that frequency that i hold
because of the declaration
i make words are
yeah words are words are spells spelling
it's in the word spelling
abracadabra abracadabra isn't that what
it is what is that
the hebrew translation as i speak so i
create
magic